A genome browser provides a way for us to
view a genome sequence along with various
pieces of information or features that
have been identified in that sequence.
You are probably most familiar with the
term "browser" in the context of an internet
browser, such as Safari, Chrome, or Firefox,
that provides a way for us to access and
search for websites on the internet. The Genome
Browser works similarly for genome sequences.
The Genome Browser we are using allows us
to view the genome assemblies of Drosophila,
or fruit fly species, although our work for these
modules will be focused on Drosophila melanogaster,
the most commonly used species in the
laboratory. Let's take a look at the various
things we can view using a genome browser.
Navigate to the Genome Browser by typing
gander.wustl.edu and clicking on the Genome
Browser link on the left side of the page.
This will take you to the gateway page. At the
gateway page, let's click to reset the browser
user interface settings to their defaults. After we
do this, we need to choose which genome we want to
investigate. Choose the D. melanogaster genome and
the July 2014 gene assembly. We will be looking
at contig1. After we hit submit, we are brought to
the view of this region. At the top of this page, we
see the name of the species and the assembly, and
the position should show contig1:1-
11 000. This means that we are viewing 11 000
base pairs of the Drosophila melanogaster genome.
We can see the base pair numbers along the row
called "scale." Let's first hit the "hide all" button,
so we can choose which features of the genome
we want to view. We use the term "features" in
bioinformatics as a catch-all term for anything
associated with the genome. Each of these features
can be highlighted or displayed along with the
genome sequence as a track that can be viewed in
the browser. We can turn on and turn off various
tracks and also adjust how each is displayed.
Let's look at a few features. Start
by clicking on the Base Position link
under Mapping and Sequencing Tracks. By clicking on
this, we can view a description of this particular
track and change its settings if we wish. As the
description states, the Base Position feature in
the Genome Browser annotations track image shows
the genomic coordinates of the displayed region
and when zoomed into the base level, you can see
the nucleotides within that region. The description
also tells us more about how to view the
individual bases. Let's go back to the browser by
clicking the back button and view this track. Right
now, the base position is set at "dense." We can't see
individual bases because we are too zoomed out.
Let's zoom in to the first 100 base pairs of this
genomic sequence by typing contig1:1-100 into the position/search
box. After we hit return, we are now able to see the
individual bases of one strand of the DNA sequence
A's, T's, C's, and G's. If you click on the arrow
below the scale contig1 label, you can see the
strand that is complementary to the top strand., in
other words, the bottom strand. Click the arrow one
more time to view the top strand again. Let's
change the base position track to "full" to see
more information associated with this feature.
Click "full" and hit "refresh." Below the bases, we
now see gray boxes. These indicate the amino acids
that are called for by each codon, or set of three
bases. There are three rows of these boxes because
there are three possible reading frames, depending
on which base is used to begin the first codon, in
other words, where the reading frame is established.
So the first reading frame at the top starts
with the very first base of the sequence.
The second reading frame starts with the second
base, and the third frame with the third base.
For each strand of DNA there are
three possible reading frames,
so there are a total of six possible reading
frames because DNA is double stranded.
Some boxes are labeled green; these are for
the amino acid methionine. Translation always
starts at a codon that codes for methionine,
which almost always has the sequence A-T-G.
The red boxes indicate stop codons. For
example, T-A-A calls for an end to translation.
Let's look at another feature: the genes that are
located in this region of the genome. Let's zoom
out to view the entire region by typing in contig1:1-11 000 in the position/search
box. Notice that we no longer see the bases or
amino acids. There is not enough room to draw
all the nucleotides and amino acids. Let's turn
on the FlyBase Gene track to "pack." This shows us
the location of genes as indicated by boxes and
lines. The names of the genes are located to the
left of each graphical representation of the gene
with the gene name shown to the left of the hyphen.
This shows us that there are three genes
in this region of the genome: CG32165,  spd-2,
and tra. For these modules, we will be spending
most of our time learning about the tra gene.